what's up y'all it's brandi evans
mercedes from pea valley
and i'm here with buzzfeed about to take
a quiz y'all that's gonna tell me what
my stripper song should be
my dream stripper song it's actually
different from what y'all probably think
i don't want anything too too hype i
want something kind of sexy and sensual
so let's see what's about to happen all
right so your friends would describe
your energy as
charismatic sensual
romantic confident or cunning man i'm
not cunning okay let's just be clear
i mean i can be romantic and sensual too
but i'm good and confident so
we gonna go with confident if you were a
stripper you'd be best at
whole dancing lap dancing stripping
twerking all of it [ __ ] i am a stripper
i love it i'm gonna go with paul dance
to know y'all cause y'all know i like to
do my stunts so i'm definitely going
with polo dance and even though i think
i could give them a run for the money on
the left too
someone saw your tips oh child no they
didn't so you
confront them brush it off because
you'll make it back
asap report them to management ain't no
snitches man
plot revenge you're not gonna end up in
jail steal their tips
i would never let that happen so that's
it right there i would never let that
happen
so don't try me y'all pick a fierce red
carpet look that speaks to you okay we
got
ribri oh you you cute nicky yes
i love a good type beyonce who don't
love me taylor swift
i'm not mad at it lady gaga okay and
mariah
okay i'm gonna have to go with nikki on
this one though she giving this little
cutout center
i'm going with nikki what's your best
physical asset
my lips okay my butt
my legs my eyes my chest
please my entire body snatches thank you
to my trainers uh please and my mama
my entire body snatches yes i'm gonna
take all this coke bottle body and these
hips and i'm gonna
snatch it on finally choose a male celeb
to give a seductive lap dance to
y'all they gonna find out what i say
drake eq
oh charles melton oh he is cute okay
okay
idris um shawn mendes donald glover
annie jonas brother y'all y'all can't do
this to me we going with idris i'm sorry
i know he's married man
but if he would
oh yeah
please
all the time why y'all know me like this
buzzfeed yes you are correct
beyonce y'all
make sure y'all tune in every sunday on
stars
to pea valley you don't want to miss
this roller coaster ride because
it's about to go down in the pink okay
i'm gonna see y'all sunday y'all
you